today I'm gonna explain the 8 best 1
shock works in my academia now for the
purposes of this list a one shot quirk
is one that can be used to effortlessly
finish someone off with a single
activation and I mean like really finish
them off there are a few powers out
there that could do this if applied in
the right way but today we're just
focusing on the ones where it can be
done the quickest with minimal effort or
minimal training but before we begin
I've done quite a few list videos before
so do be sure to check those out if
you're new to the channel and also I
just want to thank you guys so much for
getting us to 50,000 subscribers I
really appreciate it and with that said
let's get into the video ok so starting
at 8th place we have the quirk known as
warp gate which is possessed by Kira
Giri now Kira Kira is undoubtedly one of
the most overpowered characters this
series has ever seen as his quirk allows
him to open up multiple portals which he
can use to transport people to any
location as long as he knows the
coordinates or if the location is in his
line of sight the potential this has to
save money on travel is unreal
now there's an obvious reason why this
quirk is a great finishing ability if
you remember during the first season it
was cure Giri who was going to kill all
my by trapping half of his body inside
one of the portals and then closing it
thankfully back ago and Todoroki were
able to intervene before he actually did
it but the fact remains that this quote
can be using this way and the fact he
was gonna do it on all might probably
means that he could do it to the average
Joe as well we've seen firsthand that
Kira Giri can either open portals in
thin air or just fat on the ground so in
theory you could just be innocently
walking down the street one day and this
guy opens up a portal beneath your feet
and then slices you in half and I gotta
say this is one of those quirks that you
just you have to hate the fact that it's
possessed by a villain because if a hero
had this quirk they would clearly be
like one of the top here is probably a
great rescue hero as well and then to
add on top of that the fact remains that
the League of villains also have a
different warping quirk that is
possessed by all four one like why did
the villains get two of these things and
the heroes have zero not cool her Akashi
not cool
moving on to 7th place for the first
time ever on this channel we have a
three-way tie as I think it's fair to
say that all these quirks have roughly
the same potential at least regarding
the topic in this video so starting with
the only one that's actually been used
to one-shot someone
we have cremation which is a quirk
possessed by darby this grants him the
ability to conjure up powerful blue
flames
manipulate in various ways whether it be
a whirlwind a fire or just a blast of
fire or just slowly setting an entire
forest on fire this guy can do it all
his flames are likely hotter than
regular fire as well which is why they
appear blue and it's also worth noting
that endeavor said that his oldest son
Toya possessed even greater firepower
than himself now the reason this is an
instant kill work is because we
literally witnessed it being used in
this way in season 3 we see Dobby
eviscerate six guys in an instant with
just a single attack from one of his
hands
the reason is quirk is tied for seventh
is because I think it's pretty safe to
assume that his bloodline are also
capable of doing similar things which
means that both endeavor and Shoto are
included on this list and technically
speaking endeavor has used this flame to
instantly kill as well as we see him as
sinner eight this gnome his head and as
we all know no Moo's were once people
but I'll give him a pass because he kind
of had no choice and also the gnomes are
technically dead people so yeah in my
opinion at least it's also likely in the
future that shota will be able to
surpass both endeavor and Abbie's level
of firepower as the icy side of his body
allows him to regulate his temperature
better than his dad or his most likely
his brother as well this possibly means
that one day he can make his flames go
even hotter than theirs without
overheating at sixth place we have the
quirk known as one for all which is
currently held by azúcar midoriya as we
know one for all is a transferable
stockpiling ability that in its current
state essentially gives you the power of
a god it's one of the few quirks that I
would describe as genuine planet busting
world-ending quirks just to give you
some perspective when all might was well
past his prime and could only use the
power for about three hours a day I
think he was still able to perform
unbelievable feats of strength and then
after passing the power to Deku he was
able to use the dying embers of this
quirk in a variety of cool ways for
example during a practical exam all Mike
was wearing heavy weights around his
ankles and his forearms yet despite that
he was able to deliver a punch so
powerful that the wind from his punch
was strong enough to push cos into the
air destroy a bridge shatter windows and
generally just mess up the whole area
furthermore in that same episode he
traveled almost faster than the eye
could see and he says that he was
nowhere near his top speed this is all
with the dying embers of the quiet guys
he didn't have
this was like the dying embers of the
quark so as you can imagine if one flaw
was used at a hundred percent would be
true intent to actually hurt someone
they'll be finished quicker than you can
say now in fifth we have the coop black
hole which is used by 13 whilst 13 is a
rescue hero with virtually no combat
experience this quote could easily be
used not just to finish someone but to
literally tear them apart atom by atom
basically the Thanos of this universe
black hole allows the user to create
what appears to be miniaturized black
holes from their fingertips this
generates a strong gravitational pull
from which it's virtually impossible to
escape from
and once close enough to the hole
whatever is being sucked in is
disintegrated at an atomic level just
look at what they did to I armors
glasses this suction is so powerful that
much like a real-life black hole even
light can't escape from it so yeah I
think it's pretty obvious why this is a
one-shot kill quark as once the person
is close enough to be disintegrated
that's all there is to it they're gone
and due to the nature of the black hole
most people who were quote within its
range aren't really able to fight
against it as demonstrated when I am I
tried to attack only for his attacks to
be sucked up and disintegrated as well
but naturally as you would expect it's
not unbeatable
the main ones I'm thinking of our
permeation and also what gate which we
saw actually used an anime against
thirteen but for most people this quirk
is very much a one shot one kill kind of
thing now before we can get into the top
three we first have to talk about the
quirk known as fear swings which is held
by the number two pro hero Hawks I can
literally talk to you guys all day about
this one because the benefits of fear
swings you can you can come at it from a
lot of different angles but for the
purposes of this video fierce winds can
very much act as a one-shot quirk for
two reasons firstly horse controls each
individual feather with his mind meaning
that if he wants to he could hit you
with one of these things or just attack
you with dozens of feathers at once and
due to the strength of these feathers if
he wanted to he could literally end you
right there so it's a good thing he's
not a psychopath right the second thing
to know is that several of his feathers
are not just sharp but they are
literally like they're basically the
same as swords and in fact we've seen
him use these feather sores to slice
straight through no moon with incredible
ease and I think we can all acknowledge
that even the weakest of weak no mousse
it's still stronger than the average man
so if he's able to slice those things in
half with one hit you can very much
imagine what he could do to a regular
person with that being the case if he
made an active effort to concentrate one
or all of his feathers on a particular
individual using the telekinesis he
could send a sharp feather flying
towards one of your vital organs or just
swarm you with feathers to take you out
remember guys his nickname is the man
who goes too fast so you better believe
that if he wanted to finish you off with
these it would be the quickest of quick
finishes so the bronze medal on this
list goes to rewind which is one of the
next generation of quirks and it's a
pretty unique power possessed by arey so
far we've only seen this quirk used to
rewind people's bodies back to a
previous state and this was most
famously demonstrated when she helped
deck who tap into 100% of one-for-all as
she was consistently rewinding his body
so that he wouldn't break down from the
pain of using his full power now when
Aaron was a toddler she accidentally
activated this quirk which then caused
our dad to be rewound so far back but he
was wiped out of existence
you can even argue that this power isn't
an instant kill because it kind of goes
beyond death this doesn't just kill a
person but rather it reminds them so far
as if they were never even born this
quirk has a place on this list because
the user can one-shot someone with
absolutely no training I mean arey was a
toddler when she did this I think it's
inevitable that when her power grows
we'll see her be able to apply this
power in different ways one example I
was thinking of is that she could
greatly expand the range in which people
are affected by her quirk right now it
works on people that she's physically
close to but what if she could point her
finger at someone who's standing like 50
meters away and she could rewind them
back to a previous state or a different
way she could improve it is by rewinding
nonliving things so imagine your laptop
is running out of battery but then all
of a sudden she could just rewind it
back to the morning when it was fully
charged although if she did that you'd
probably lose all your save data so be
careful but with that all said we're
down to the final two places so in
second place we have the quirk folder
body which is possessed by the number
four pro hero headshot I already
explained this quote on my list of best
transformation quirks so today I'm just
gonna pinpoint why it's a great one
shock walk instead because ed Shaw is
able to transform his body into varying
degrees of thinness he often uses it to
mess around with people's insides -
spoilers here but in the manga we've
seen ed Shaw used this quirk to turn
himself into a thin
line and then pierced through the lungs
of at least 12 villains in an instant by
doing this move the villains were unable
to move properly afterwards without
causing themselves serious damage
similarly in the anime we see him go
inside Kira Giri and mess around with
his body until he was not unconscious
bearing that in mind it would take
minimal effort for the number 4 hero to
actually one-shot someone with this
quirk I will admit though Etra himself
is the one that makes this power as
great as it is but as I said at the
beginning we're looking at quirks where
one shooting can be done quickly and
with minimal effort or training in this
case I think it's fair to say the
edgehog could do it with minimal effort
and so for that reason he ranks 2nd
place on this list and finally guys in
first place we have a tie for the best
one-shot work as these two powers are
very similar but crucially they have
different aspects to them that the other
quark user doesn't possess so starting
with the big guy we have kaiju sake
otherwise known as overhaul as we saw in
season 4 this is as much of an instant
kill quirk as you could possibly get his
ability lets him disassemble anything he
touches and then once he's destroyed
something he has the option to either
mold it into something new or just
restore it to its original form
we saw him use this to explode Magna
with a single touch and in that same
episode he then did the same thing to
mr. compress his arm we also witnessed
later on in the season that he turned
one of his henchmen into a stain on the
wall again with a single touch one of
the great things about this power is
that it can also one-shot you from long
range as well as he can touch the ground
and just make these spikes come out one
of which was used to obviously kill sir
Knight I so yeah he can kill you from
long range
short range it doesn't matter to this
guy what makes this better than every
other croc on this list is that it won't
just finish someone off quickly but if
the user wants to and if they act
quickly enough they can bring someone
back from the dead overall use this
quirk to literally kill rapper but then
a few seconds later he used the
reassembling part of his quirk to bring
him back to life so with that in mind
the power that this person has is
incredible to be honest not just
physically as well like psychologically
if you're going up against someone who
you know can kill you right now bring
you back to life kill you again bring
you back to life like you just don't
want to mess with that person like in
any circumstance well unless you're this
guy who just for some reason keeps going
back for more but then that raises the
question
what quirk out there could possibly be
tied at number one with a quirk like
that well the answer is one that I'm
sure many of you have been anticipating
but to put you out of your suspense the
joint best instant kill quirk is decay
which is possessed by tomorrow sugar aki
who is the main antagonist of maya
academia at its most basic form decay
allows the user to disintegrate anything
they touch with all five fingers and
we've seen this quirk actually evolved
throughout the series during the first
season when he used this quell Kanazawa
the decay was bad and it really messed
up aizawa's arm but by season four he
was disintegrating people's entire
bodies with a single touch so you don't
get more one shot than that
now I'm gonna go into some manga
spoilers on how this quirk has evolved
even further so for those of you that
don't want to know skip to the timestamp
on screen to get a look at my honorable
mentions but for the rest of you in
Milan academia we saw the sugar Aki
awakened his quirk so that firstly he
can decay without needing to make
contact with all five fingers we also
see that he can now decay with his feet
as well and crucially this is probably
the main thing he can decay things that
are connected to things he's touched
this enabled him to create a meteor
sized crater in the middle of a city as
when he was decaying the ground
everything connects to the ground just
disintegrated and then things connected
to that disintegrated it was just it was
a mess so this won't one-shot people in
your general area like overalls quirk
this will one-shot an entire city or an
entire neighborhood so yeah they are
they do have different benefits mainly
the overhaul can actually reverse the
impact of his quirk and use it in
different ways whereas shigaraki is just
literally pure destruction so while
these two quarks are similar is clear
that they also have very differing
additional benefits and so for that
reason they both take first place and
deservedly so
and before we round out this video I'm
gonna give three honorable mentions very
quickly so the first one is mushroom and
as I explained on my list of secretly
powerful quirks mushroom can be used to
suffocate someone by manifesting shrooms
inside their throat and lungs
the second honorable mention is compress
and while it isn't really an instant
kill quirk in most situations if mr.
Campos wanted to he could seal someone
away inside these marbles and then just
never release them so while they
wouldn't be dead
they won't exactly have a life either
also it's kind of interesting to
theorize whether a person ages if stuck
inside one of these mob
putting them aside being lost honorable
mention is food which is a quirk
possessed by table a from these she his
Ike I've now this quirk lets him chomp
through anything and everything and we
actually saw him eat one of Tamaki's
limbs okay fair enough it was an octopus
limb but it was still attached to Tamaki
so if this guy was crazy enough and if
he got close enough I have no doubt that
he can bite your head clean off but I
thought they'd do that in this series
maybe in vigilantes though those are my
three honorable mentions but do be sure
to let me know if you think I miss
anything out on the main list or if you
would rank characters differently thanks
for watching as always and peace out